Diamonds come with a lot cultural implications
because, in part, they're rare!
But what if you could just make some?
Hey there my precious little gemstones, Trace
with ya on DNews today.
Geologists are still figuring out the exact
details, but we know nature’s recipe for
diamonds is carbon, heat, and pressure.
Naturally-formed diamonds start with carbon
dioxide buried some 100 miles deep in the
Earth’s mantle.
At those depths, there’s incredible heat
and pressure from the rock above, which is
good!
The heat of about 2,200 degrees Fahrenheit
and the pressure of 725,000 pounds per square
inch
causes the carbon to crystallize, forming
a diamond.
And with each carbon atom bonded to four others,
it’s one of the hardest materials on Earth.
The diamond is then punted up to the surface
hitching a ride on lava flows.
And because they’re coming from deep in
the Earth, diamonds are really old!
This process happened anywhere from hundreds
of millions of years ago to a few billion
years ago.
There are a few other things that can also
produce diamonds, like meteor impacts.
These more recent events have the same combination
of heat and pressure, so if carbon is present,
it can crystallize into a diamond.
But again, this isn’t something happening
everyday.
Luckily for those among us with a penchant
for pretty, shiny things, we can also make
diamonds in a lab!
To be clear, a synthetic diamond isn’t the
same as cubic zirconia -- which is a gem made
in a lab from zirconium dioxide (it doesn’t
have the same composition as a diamond) A
lab-made diamond is a diamond with the exact
same physical structure and chemical composition
as a stone that’s been mined from the ground.
Which means the recipe is the same: carbon,
heat, and pressure.
One way of making a synthetic diamond is the
“high pressure high temperature” method.
Graphite (yup, pencil lead!) is squeezed by
tiny anvils in a machine while being zapped
by intense bursts of electricity.
In a few days, that graphite will have crystallized
into a diamond, though it won't be pure since
there's a metallic solution in the graphite.
Another method is called chemical vapor deposition.
A piece of diamond is put into a depressurizing
chamber filled with natural gas.
As the gas is zapped with a microwave beam,
it get hot.
This causes carbon atoms to “fall” and
attach themselves to the diamond.
They stick to it making the diamond grow,
turning it into a sheet of pure diamond overnight.
You can even make diamonds in a microwave!
But please don’t try this at home because
it’s dangerous.
A tiny fragment of diamond is put into a microwave
with a carbon-heavy gas like methane.
The gas is heated to produce a plasma ball,
inside of which the gas breaks down.
The carbon atoms then stick to the diamond
fragment, causing it to grow.
This process can take up to ten weeks before
you’d get a diamond large enough to sell,
but the resulting stones are so pure even
gemologists need machines to tell them apart
from mined stones.
Diamonds are more than just pretty, sparkly
things that you wear.
Here are seven really neat uses for diamonds
out in the real world!
Would you be happy with a diamond made in
a lab or do you need the real thing?
Let us know in the comments, subscribe and
come back for more DNews everyday.